[Music]
so we've done a lot of crossing
zigzagging across Criss crossing the
play or the play are in front of us
going forwards going backwards but
there's also a whole lot of pull-ups
that require the ploy to you a criss
cross from front to back and a lot of
them are going to learn where they go
over the head so that's a new space we
need to open up so you can take one play
and we're gonna face this way you're
going to hold it behind your head with
it with both hands and I want you to use
both hands because that's gonna make you
do it in the center rather than doing
off the side where it might feel easier
because I want you to learn to do it
right over the top so both hands and
head up if you put your head down it
won't work because it's not behind you
anymore so head up so the boys hanging
behind you and all you're going to do is
you're going to get it swinging and try
to learn to do some circles in one
direction and then some circles in the
other direction and that can be you know
I can go all that can you floppy at
first to be awkward
but I just wanted you get started
circles this way circles this way II I'm
gonna mirror you for a moment until you
can feel like okay I can get them going
this way and I can get them going this
way so let's do this face me and you're
going to get the circle where the points
coming up on that side so for me I look
over there I've got it's big mountains
and I think at the point come up the
mountains that's one or two circles
that's the mountains no they can look
that way I can get that this is a tree I
can get it coming up to the tree and
it's a new space back here so don't
worry if that's awkward so let's stick
with this one and whatever you got over
there for me it's mountains poof-poof
what you're going to do is you're going
to go from that circle come in the front
do circle in front also for me up the
mountains so make sure it's coming up
over there because some people will
switch for that clockwise
counterclockwise thing what you want to
make sure it's up over there and then in
front it's also up over there
and then you're gonna try to do this
you're gonna go up over there up over
there so one behind one in front behind
in front or two behind one in front
behind front and your brain will start
to map that it's the same thing just
one's a few in front of your head ones
behind then it becomes rhythm we can
start in front now because we've sort of
primed that or you get your play going
in front and you just get a rhythm going
one two three four and make sure the poi
is straight up and down or even tilted
in at the bottom all right so it's close
to your knees and you're gonna do this
you're gonna go one two three four one
two three four and just trust the rhythm
it might feel like it's not gonna work
but reach all the way behind you and
don't drop your head if you drop your
head you'll go like this right because
the back your head is now above you
instead of behind you need to stand
really tall and you go one two three
four and really try to touch the ground
behind you one two three four one two
three four one two three four and one of
those things that I often see people it
works and they don't believe it works
until they've done it enough so if it
gets back in front and still going the
same way you've done it 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
and eventually 1 2 3 4 now I know from
experience a lot of people start
dropping their head and then it doesn't
work because they're not getting they
can't get behind enough you've really
got to stand tall 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 when
it works one way you can do all the same
steps the other way
give me the pike on the other side I'm
taking it from behind front from behind
the front and then starting in front 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and once
that works you can do it with one hand
at a time to where each hand right over
the top of the head though right over
the top of the head one way
and the other way with your left hand
and then one way and the other way with
your right hand super important to learn
so much that requires us and when you've
got it we can we're gonna learn through
this butterfly we're gonna learn
windmill we're gonna learn those some of
the main ones Mexican wave taking one
plate out and then the other run out all
goes over the head so I I think that
will work for most of you it doesn't
just show me and I'll get you through it
the sun's setting it's nice
I'm glad I found this perk I was where
do I shoot in Vancouver and then I find
the spark it's a little loud but it's
nice
[Music]